maxime thiébaut docteur en droit public
maxime thibeault bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors première
réaction qu'avez vous pensé des
déclarations du commissaire européen
thierry breton l'immunité collective au
14 juillet est ce crédible selon vous
alors je les trouvais particulièrement
confus c'est à dire que lui même ne
croyait pas s'il nous racontait le
problème c'est qu'on sait pertinemment
qu'une unité sera impossible au 14
juillet parce que cela supposerait 700
mille doses par jour pour parvenir à
avoir une immunité en france et on sait
très bien que la politique vaccinale
française est catastrophique parce que
l'union européenne n'a pas su la gérer
et c'est là où je suis particulièrement
déçu de monsieur breton c'est à dire que
hier au 20 heures de tf1
il aurait dû essayer de réconcilier les
français avec la politique de l'union
européenne et au lieu de ça il s'est
satisfait de leur échec
il a été dans l'auto congratulation et
finalement on a vu que les français ne
pouvaient rester que méfiants à l'égard
d'une politique qui n'a pas fonctionné
alors les français qui sont à méfiants à
l'égard de la politique méfiant
également à l'égard d'un certain vaccin
qui se nomme astrazeneca
on l'a vu auparavant avec ce dernier
sondage qui a été publié aujourd'hui à
61% des français qui ne font pas
confiance au sérum anglo-suédois il
avait été question du sérum spoutnik v
on sait qu'actuellement la haute
autorité de santé européennes se penche
sur le vaccin russe pourtant hier on a
senti
des propos qui ne vont pas dans le même
sens de la part du commissaire européen
qui veut donner la priorité aux vaccins
fabriqués sur le territoire européen
l'europe qui ne devrait pas avoir besoin
d'avoir voile a demandé l'aide de la
russie avec le
vaccins sont ni gris c'est quand même
particulièrement cocasse que l'union
européenne qui depuis des années nous
vend le principe de libre concurrence
le principe de libre entreprise sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
viennent aujourd'hui stoppée le scout 5
au simple motif qu'en fait elle raisonne
par dogmatisme
on est encore dans l'idéologie d'une
européenne qui déteste la russie sans
aucune raison alors que aujourd'hui le
seul objectif c'est d'assurer la santé
des français
et moi je regrette très fortement que le
cieux breton ne fasse pas passer la
sécurité des français avant son
dogmatisme complètement aberrant sont
sur d'autres mathis non européens
c'est à dire en faisant confiance à ce
vaccin qui fonctionne et l'objectif
aujourd'hui la ccin c'est de rendre aux
français leur liberté depuis presque un
an
on ne connaît que des mesures de
restriction parce que le gouvernement a
été incapable de rouvrir des lits de
réanimation ou d'assurer une politique
vaccinale digne de ce nom
alors aujourd'hui j'aimerais entendre de
nos responsables politiques fassent
preuve d'un peu de courage qu'ils
arrêtent être leur dogmatisme
complètement débile parce que là on est
vraiment dans la débilité la plus
profonde et il fasse preuve d'ouverture
d'esprit en admettant tous les vaccins
qui ont prouvé études fonctionnelles
c'est une décision politique
à votre avis qui va être prise
concernant le vaccin russe mais bien sûr
mais c'est une décision politique qui
est prise et c'est ça qui est terry qui
est terrible depuis depuis plusieurs
mois c'est qu'aujourd'hui la seule
politique disons que ce soit monsieur
verges sur le sol castex monsieur breton
c'est la politique du sophisme c'est à
dire qu'ils nous sortent des vérités
sorti de nulle part qui se permettent
d'avoir des arguments qui sont
complètement infondées
tout simplement parce qu'il raisonne par
dogmatisme ils ne veulent pas aller
chercher des vaccins ailleurs que dans
leur production européenne qui ne
fonctionne pas et dont il continue de
nous imposer des mesures de restriction
qui ne tiennent pas la route et que
personne ne comprendra vous voyez le le
confinement qui ne porte pas son nom
enfin c'est complètement aberrant et il
continue à l'être cette politique qui
est ainsi construite deux dogues mathis
mhz au lieu de défendre nos libertés et
d'assurer en fait la sécurité des
français parce que tout le temps qu'on
passe à ne pas vacciner les français
c'est du temps qu'on passe
sacrifier les plus vulnérables et des
personnes qui ont besoin d'être taxés la
russie qui a multiplié les accords de
production notamment avec plusieurs pays
l'inde de 100 millions de doses qui vont
être fabriqués sur le territoire indien
l'italie également qui a décidé de mener
elles-mêmes des des essais cliniques sur
le vaccin et qui voit la désespère
d'obtenir le feu vert à des autorités
européennes en tout cas ce sont des
essais qui vont être menées en
collaboration avec moscou et puis
l'allemagne il ya quelques jours qu'ils
disaient voilà quelques algues étaient
en fait l'arrivée du vaccin russe en
europe est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
chancelière allemande angela merkel peut
faire changer les choses
la chancelière angela merkel
elle défend son pays le président macron
devrait défendre la france imaginez
qu'on vit la crise la plus terrible
qu'on connaisse depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale et au lieu d'avoir le premier
ministre ou président de la république
qui s'exprime au 20 heures de tf1 pour
nous parler de la politique vaccinale
honda monsieur breton qui est lui de
personnes qui ne représentent personne
et y intervient pour dire face à la
guerre parce que c'est comme ça que
monsieur macro nous présente le coït une
grande bière et la face à la guerre on
va interdire l'utilisation de certaines
armes et en l'occurrence le spoutnik 5
donc moi je trouve ça particulièrement
cocasse de voir que ce n'est plus la
france qui gouvernent mais c'est l'union
européenne alors que cette dernière a
complètement échoué dans la politique
vaccinale est qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
terriblement retard tout simplement
parce qu'elle ne fait pas de la
realpolitik
c'est à dire qu'elle ne fait pas de la
géopolitique ne négocie pas mais qu'elle
est dans ses rêves et dans ses rêves
doux comme d'habitude et bien le
sacrifie les peuples euros les peuples
d'europe et l sacrifiant maintenant les
français
merci beaucoup maxime thibon avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en droit
public